hello and welcome back to blame reveal
my name is Caleb Denby and today we're
going to be going over a world
championship candidates game against one
of the youngest grandmasters in history
so we'll see how somebody at the top
level of chess it does against someone
who's up-and-coming perhaps a future top
10 player of course I'm talking about
this game between wang hao and prague
ananda ramesh or yet just prague ananda
what we'll call him that's his last name
i believe but i get confused on these
things the game went c4 for wang hao e5
Knight c3 Knight f6 Knight f3 knight c6
III Bishop b4 Queen c2 Bishop takes c3 B
takes c3 so some opening decisions have
already been made
this is an opening line that has been
tried many many many times Carlson has
played this with white people like Topal
of sergey karaoke and Levon Aronian and
well played it with black and the idea
is black trades off this bishop which on
is on the same color as his pawns takes
away some control of this d5 square for
for white meanwhile white has doubled
his pawns but this gives him a little
bit more central control than than
before
in this case though black just plays d6
white now plays efore taking advantage
of this c3 pawn boxing out this Knight a
little bit black castles we see g3 white
choosing this diagonal for the bishop as
the c4 pawn is kind of in it's in it's
way over here 97 is blacks choice
perhaps rerouting to the c5 square
perhaps freeing up some potential f5
breaks Bishop g2 this Knight does come
to c5 now we see Knight h4 for white
perhaps eyeing the potential f5 brick a6
is black's choice things like b5 are
going to come for black he's kind of
committed to these Knights being on this
Queen side here so it makes sense for
him to want to expand on this side of
the board white castles black does
continue with b5 we
the Nazi b5 which has been played
historically but instead d4 following a
game of Peters Fiddler's with black
he takes d4 C takes D for this night is
attacked and then black laughs at white
and says haha you hung upon you're so
stupid white says okay
I apologize and plays Queen B -
attacking this night and getting some
activity the point of this pawn
sacrifice of course is that this 'if
I've pawn has now been removed and with
the removal of this 'if I've pawned and
of course allows white an opportunity
here that opportunity is to play e5
himself opening up this Bishop on the
long diagonal this was the point of the
sacrifice for white of course he didn't
just hang upon he sacrificed it to open
up these diagonals for this bishop now
you might be tempted to play Bishop b7
which is a fine move but white will
simply start regaining some pawns here
play move like see b5 and after a b5
Queen takes b5 is potentially playable
but you can also play stuff like Knight
f5 already threatening some annoying
checkmates so instead we actually see
Bishop d7 because of this Knight f5 move
it now keeps an eye on both of these
things white still continues with a
takes d6 we see C takes D 6 and now
Queen d2 is White's choice eyeing this
d6 pawn now black simply plays rook to
c8 adding some extra defense to this c6
Knight once again you can take on d6 but
perhaps you're sowing your shelf
yourself a bit short blacks now going to
reroute the night and find some activity
with this c4 square so instead of Queen
d6 white first captures on b5 and now
perhaps black should have recaptured you
know it's usually a good idea in chess
when your opponent takes your pieces for
you to take them back prague however
wanted to be a little bit more ambitious
and actually play this move Knight e5
here and this move is kind of asking for
trouble
white accepts this kind of sacrifice and
takes on a6 and the point of
prague ananda was to play Bishop b5 he
thinks he's definitely gonna regain this
pawn with no trouble and now he gets to
kind of play with these pieces a little
bit kick around these major pieces for
white and try and create some awkward
threats wong hau simply brings this rook
to d1 and now this bishop comes to a
four once again hitting this rook so it
comes to e1 now but now prague plays
Knight c to d 3 once again hitting this
rook so the short comes back to f1 where
it originally started and while Prague
has succeeded in pushing around these
these major pieces specifically the rook
of long house he hasn't really achieved
anything by this you might claim that
these pieces have been improved by this
positioning but actually they're they're
a little bit loose they're a little bit
susceptible to some threats that long
how is going to create because they're a
little overextended actually and so I
think this whole maneuver with Bishop b5
- a for bringing the knight to d3
well White has in fact just moved this
rook around for the past 4 moves I think
black might have actually weakened his
position with all of this and so now
Rick's e2 was an additional point for
Prague kicking around a major piece once
again this Queen comes to e3 but now in
fact you have to be a little bit careful
of things maybe even like f4 hitting
this Knight and preparing to to create
some nasty threats against this knight
in the game Prague plays Knight c5 just
actually retreating the knight to c5
because of some of these threats and in
fact this is actually now kind of a
waste of time for black he brought this
night to d3 with tempo and now he brings
it back to c5 without tempo and this
allows one count try and hold on to this
pawn a little bit longer plays this move
a5 and prague brings this bishop back to
c6 keeping an eye on the a8 square we do
in fact see a trade of bishops and now
after Queen f3 probably is still eyeing
this a 8 square you can play a move like
Knight takes a 7 but in fact this that's
going to be a little bit out of play and
you're allowing white some time to play
a move like Knight f5 this is really the
key move in the position for white it I
is the king
as well as this week d6 pawn so you
don't really want to waste all your time
putting this knight on a 7 so instead we
see the much more active move Knight d4
I think this one's good we see Knight
beef or a queen d5 in return 92 check
hits the King King comes to g2 and now
Knight c3 turns out to be a kind of
fatal mistake
4 for Prague here and it's a little bit
difficult to understand why but once
again we see Prague kind of succumbing
to the temptation to push around this
white queen or this white rook when in
fact what he's done here is actually
improved the white queen and you really
wouldn't expect that you would expect d5
to be the ideal Square for the Queen but
in fact in this case f3 is actually a
better Square and there's a very
specific reason for that and we'll see
that after Queen a8 this Knight comes to
f5 and very naturally black can capture
this a7 pawn but now the point is kind
of revealed as to why f3 is a bit better
than d5 and the reasoning is absolutely
clear after White's next move now white
did not find this move in the game but
he had actually a very nice opportunity
to kind of end the game on the spot I'll
let you at home try and find the
devastating tactic but okay pause the
video now if you want to try to find it
we'll see it in just a moment here of
course the move is Bishop to h6
this move is simply devastating in this
point I'm talking about from d5 this
Queen would not have a way to get to the
G file but from f3 we do have Queen g4
in Queen g7 if white were if black were
to capture this Bishop and this is kind
of a devastating point and there's
simply no good way to respond to this
threat for black you can play Queen a it
Queen eight I'm simply going to capture
this pawn and after a trade of Queens
and rook e8 this is simply kind of
hopeless for for black you do maybe get
this pawn back but all these threats are
on the black King are going to be far
too much to handle
so Bishop h6 would have been the nice
finish to the game well the game would
on the spot per se but the endgame is
just completely hopeless instead though
Wong Cao played the simple Bishop f4
which is giving black a little bit of an
opportunity to hold on for a little bit
perhaps black should play tonight 3 to
e4 defending this pawn a little bit and
now maybe Bishop h6 is still playable
but it comes with much less devastating
effects due to this Knight g5 idea here
and black might be holding off instead
though Prague played knight c6 which is
simply allowing too much with Bishop
takes d6 now Knight g5 this Queen comes
to c6 and after Queen a8 Wang cow is not
shy in entering the second game because
this well rook and minor piece endgame
because the son game is actually quite
nice after a 3 this extra pawn is a
little bit too tough to deal with for
Prague
he plays Knight G to e4 pinning this
bishop long how actually plays rook a to
C 1 and we see some trades go into
effect after g6
97 check King f8 is this choice you can
come to e5 but now you'll be hit with
the Bishop e5 check and it takes and it
takes and the son game is is not going
to be pleasant
instead he comes to f8 where you find
Knight takes g6 check anyways and after
King g7 this Knight actually comes back
to h4 like does take this opportunity to
get rid of the smilling bishop but at
the end of the day while black does
regain this pawn on a3 the fact is this
end game is very very difficult for
black and the reason is yes White's up a
pawn that's not always enough and these
types of end games but more importantly
than that is his king this King is going
to be pinned to the back rank thanks to
this glorious glorious night and
together this knight in this rook are
going to create some very very awkward
threats around this camp and you see
Rick c7 now and this is really the the
problem for for Black Knight h6 is
always going to be a threat to pick up
this f7 pawn if this trick ever leaves
the back rank of course
is a checkmate and the only way to
really try and even remotely solve these
problems is you have to play your kf8
and you can see now the the crushing
advantage in activity that this extra
pawn grants white of course in the
endgame the king is a fighting piece so
this rook or this knight in this rook
are both already extremely active pieces
so Wang Hao activates his final piece
with King f3 and now King III let me see
a check King f4 snake comes to d2 and
now simply f3 guarding the e4 square
this rook does return to f8 to defend
against that threat h4 King h8 h v king
g8 black just has to pass Wang cow takes
all of the space in the position and now
plays Knight h6 and after King g7 simply
king g4 and you can see this might be
coming but after Knight f1 night of 5
check King g8 rook d7 white doesn't even
have to commit to something like f4 f5
and f6 because this Knight is simply in
an inescapable box as soon as you move
this rook away I'm going to play Knight
h6 check and collect this pawn and if
you don't move this work away I'm going
to ever so slowly come capture your
knight and that is why after rook d7
Prague Ananda resigned so this was
actually a very impressive game from
Wang Hao he he found this extra pawn and
then he turned it into this activity
advantage and he really didn't let off
the gas and showed Prague what he's made
of
I showed Prague why he is in the
candidates in this upcoming twenty20
tournament of course I think wang hao is
actually the underdog to look out for
for the candidates so keep an eye on him
as he plays some very interesting chess
games some very nice chess games as this
chess career continues as always my name
is Caleb Denby and I'd like to thank you
for joining me on this episode of game
review